[QUIET MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi.
I'm Andrea.
I am a second-year master
student at the Media Lab.
And so this is some of my work.
My work ranges from
wearable sculpture
to large-scale public
art installations.
And I'm now working in a lab
that designs from the micro
to macro scale, using tools
that work with nature.
My name is Nicolas
Kisic Aguirre.
I'm a recent graduate
of the ACT program,
so that's Art, Culture
and Technology.
It's basically the visual
arts program at MIT.
Although it's all
about visual studies,
my concentration or my focus has
been over the past three years
in sound.
I try to understand how
sound effects public space
and how public spaces are space
for [? politics. ?] To have
a perspective in
this, I make machines,
and these machines
end up being my tools
to have a voice in
the construction
of the sonic soundscape.
Hi.
So I'm Brian Huang.
I'm a senior majoring in
computer science and finance.
There's a industrial
[INAUDIBLE] dress that I made.
It was inspired mostly by like
a sense of a nebulous future
and what could be coming
after undergraduate, which is
kind of where I am right now.
Well, I have my second show on
the [INAUDIBLE] Room at MIT.
It featured six looks,
four womenswear looks
and two menswear looks.
And basically it was a
progression from youthfulness
into sort of unclear
future and adulthood.
My name is Gary Zhexi Zhang.
I'm a graduate student in the
first year of the Art, Culture,
Technology program.
In my work, I'm predominantly
a filmmaker and a writer.
And the films that
I'm presenting here
were made over the
past couple of years
on a number of different themes
between politics of identity
and authenticity
in Chinese history,
but also on the intersection
of contemporary technology
and biology.